>> Juan: WELCOME BACK.
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WAGING A
WAR AGAINST JURISDICTIONS THAT
PROVIDE SANCTUARY TO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
NOW THEY HAVE RELEASED
CONCERN.
MORE THAN 100 SUSPECTED MEMBERS
OF MS-13 AND OTHER GANGS WERE
RELEASED IN SANCTUARY CITIES
LAST YEAR, AND THAT CAME DESPITE
REQUEST FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT THEY BE HELD.
THIS IS A BREAKDOWN BY STATE.
TWO-THIRDS OF THOSE RELEASED
OCCURRED IN CALIFORNIA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SET ON TWITTER
TODAY:
"CALIFORNIA'S DANGEROUS POLICIES
RELEASE VIOLENT CRIMINALS BACK
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES, PUTTING
ALL AMERICANS AT RISK."
HE THANKED SAN DIEGO COUNTY FOR
BACKING THE LAWSUIT AGAINST THE
STATE.
>> Kimberly: WE SEEM TO GO
BACK AND FORTH ON THIS.
IT'S REALLY GOT TO BE PRETTY
ACCELERATED AND OUT-OF-CONTROL
IN CALIFORNIA.
I REMEMBER THE GOOD OLD DAYS
WHEN I WAS FIRST LADY IN
SAN FRANCISCO, SEEMS LIKE IT WAS
MUCH MORE SANE HAVE THE TIME.
NOW YOU HAVE SUCH A BIG,
AGGRESSIVE PUSH.
YOUR BACKLASH FROM CERTAIN
COUNTIES TO SAY WAIT A SECOND.
WE WANT TO FOLLOW THE LAW.
WE WANT TO UPHOLD THE LAW, WE
WANT FAIRNESS, WE ARE SEEKING
JUSTICE, NOT INJUSTICE.
WE WANT TO COME TO THE -- WE
WANT PEOPLE TO COME TO THE
COUNTRY LEGALLY.
THAT'S HOW IT SHOULD BE.
WHEN YOU SEE THE LAW BROKEN AND
PEOPLE COMING IN COME OUT
REVOLVING DOORS, IT'S NOT
HELPING THE IMMIGRANTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES, CHILDREN.
PEOPLE GET SEPARATED.
NOT HELPING THE LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND ORDINANCES
IN THE BORDER.
IT'S FRAUGHT WITH COMPLICATIONS
AND PROBLEMS.
THIS IS AN ISSUE PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS NOT GOING TO GIVE UP ON BUT
IT ALSO SEEMS THE GOVERNOR BROWN
IS DIGGING IN.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR NEWSOM IS
DIGGING IN.
IT'S BECOMING A VERY LARGE
POLITICAL ISSUE FOR THE UPCOMING
GUBERNATORIAL ELECTION.
>> Juan: JESSE COME HELP ME
OUT OF THE AUDIENCE UNDERSTANDS
WHAT'S AT STAKE.
THE SANCTUARY CITIES LEGISLATION
SAYS BASICALLY IF YOU HAVE YOUR
AVERAGE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT IN
JAIL.
THEY GET OUT OF JAIL.
THE CITY OR STATE HAS NO
OBLIGATION TO NOTIFY THE FEDS.
BUT IF IT'S A VIOLENT CRIMINAL,
THEY WILL YOU KNOW.
THEN OF COURSE IF THERE IS A
DETAINER OR WARRANT, THEY ARE
OBLIGATED.
>> Jesse: IN FITS OF FELONY
THEY ARE HOLDING AMONG, GIVES
THE LOCAL DISCRETION TO CONTACT
THE FEDS.
THERE'S OTHER ELEMENTS.
IF YOU PULL OVER A GUY FOR
RUNNING A RED LIGHT AND HE HAS
TATTOOS ALL OVER HIS FACE, NO
I.D., CAN'T SPEAK ENGLISH, YOU
CAN'T EVEN ASK HIM ABOUT HIS
CITIZENSHIP.
THEY RESTRICT IC ACCESS TO
PRISONS.
YOU CAN'T HOLD ON THE LEGAL
IMMIGRANT LONGER THAN YOU WOULD
OTHERWISE WHILE YOU WAIT FOR THE
FEDS.
>> Juan: WHAT DOES THE
PRESIDENT WANTS?
>> Jesse: THE PRESIDENT WANTS
THE SANCTUARY CITIES DEFUNDED.
>> Juan: THAT THEY WOULD COME
EVEN WITH SOMEONE WHO WASN'T A
CRIMINAL OR A VIOLENT CRIMINAL,
THAT THEY WILL HOLD THEM UNTIL
THE FEDS COME GET THEM.
>> Jesse: I THINK THEY WOULD
PRIORITIZE IT.
IF THAT SOMEONE NOT HERE LEGALLY
AND IT'S A SMALL THING, MAYBE
SHOPLIFTING OR SOMETHING TINY.
OBVIOUSLY THE     THE FEDS ARE O
OBVIOUSLY THE     THE FEDS ARE N
OBVIOUSLY THE     THE FEDS ARE
OBVIOUSLY THE     THE FEDS ARE O
PRIORITIZE.
IF SOMEONE PUNCHES YOU IN THE
FACE, STEALS A CAR, SELLING
NARCOTICS, SOMETHING BIG.
THEN THE PRESIDENT WANTS I.C.E.
TO BE ABLE TO GO IN THERE AND
GET THOSE GUYS AND SHIP THEM
OUT.
>> Juan: KENNEDY, WITH THE
NUMBERS SHOW COMING FROM THE
PRESIDENT AND WHITE HOUSE TODAY.
37 JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
ENGAGING THIS KIND KIND OF
BEHAVIOR.
OBVIOUSLY CALIFORNIA,
TWO-THIRDS.
WASHINGTON STATE ALSO INVOLVED.
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Kennedy: IF THAT'S HOW THE
STATES WANT TO PLAY IT, THAT'S
FINE.
IF THEY WANT TO OPERATE
INDEPENDENTLY, I DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT.
I HAPPEN TO HAVE A VERY HIGH
OPINION OF MOST IMMIGRANTS WHO
COME TO THE COUNTRY BECAUSE MOST
DON'T COMMIT CRIMES AND THEY
WORK VERY HARD.
I HATE TO SEE THEM LUMPED IN
WITH MEMBERS OF MS-13.
THE PROBLEM IS IF YOU ARE
LETTING BAD PEOPLE GO AND
ENTERING INTO SOCIETY AND
HURTING PEOPLE, THEY GET REALLY
GOOD AT NOT GETTING ARRESTED AND
CONTINUING TO COMMIT CRIMES.
THAT'S NOT OKAY.
YOU END UP HAVING A DISINGENUOUS
CONVERSATION ABOUT IMMIGRATION
AND ABOUT CRIME.
UNFORTUNATELY IMMIGRANTS GET
TIRED IS BEING REALLY BAD PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO HURT YOU AND TAKE
YOUR STUFF.
BY AND LARGE, THAT'S JUST NOT
THE CASE.
I LOVE CALIFORNIA.
IT'S A GREAT STATE, AND I HATE
TO SEE IT TORN APART.
I HATE TO SEE THIS STATE TURNED
INTO "YOU ARE ON OUR TEAM OR
YOU'RE NOT."
FOR US OR AGAINST IT.
WE HAVE BAD IMMIGRATION POLICY
FROM THE TOP THAT IS TOO
CONFUSING FOR STATES AND
COUNTIES.
>> Kimberly: VERY POLARIZING.
MAKE A GREAT POINT.
YOU SEE THIS INJUSTICE, SO MANY
HARDWORKING MEN AND WOMEN AND
CHILDREN THAT GREW UP IN THIS
COUNTRY, FANTASTIC IMMIGRANT
BACKGROUNDS LIKE MY FAMILY.
THEY CONTRIBUTE TO SOCIETY AND
WANT TO DO WITH THE RIGHT WAY.
IT'S UNFAIR TO STIGMATIZE IT.
THE LAWLESSNESS CANNOT BE
IGNORED.
YOU SEE PEOPLE LIKE MS-13 WHO I
HAD TO PROSECUTE WHEN I WAS A
D.A. IN SAN FRANCISCO,
LOS ANGELES.
THE HORRIFIC CRIMES.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO
COME IN AND REENTER AGAIN.
>> Juan: TYRUS, I DON'T THINK
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT YOU WITH
THE TATTOOS.
>> Tyrus: I HAVE TATTOOS BUT I
WAS BORN IN MASSACHUSETTS, SO I
AM GOOD.
I GREW UP IN CALIFORNIA.
I DON'T SEE THE UPSIDE OF THE
ARGUMENT.
I TRY TO LOOK AT THINGS DOWN THE
MIDDLE.
IF YOU ARE HERE ILLEGALLY, YOU
ARE ALREADY BREAKING THE LAW.
IF YOU DO SOMETHING, YOU SHOULD
BE HELD.
IF YOU ROB, STEAL, DO THINGS.
IF YOU ARE A NORMAL AMERICAN
CITIZEN AND YOU HAD A WARRANT,
THEY ARE GOING TO HOLD YOU.
IT'S ONLY FAIR.
THE WORST THING IS, THEY ARE
ENCOURAGING GANG MEMBERS TO
BRING MORE GUYS OVER BECAUSE THE
WORST THAT WILL HAPPEN IS YOU
WILL DO SOMETHING AND THEY WILL
LET YOU GO.
>> Jesse: THEY KNOW CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA.
>> Tyrus: THEY KNOW THE LAW
BETTER THAN THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
RESTING.
THEY KNOW THE SYSTEM BETTER THAN
THE SYSTEM.
>> Juan: I WORRY.